o angolado foto foi o lado pessoal daqui
que fala e rodar que sejam muito bem
vindos já mais um vídeo e o estrago já
que é bom e eu com sustentação gostaram
mostrar as minhas coisas por estar aqui
minha caneca nova vacina não tem é só
minha
não não conheço bem este parece ser mais
interessante e oum calma contigo deixam
perceber onde é que está o primeiro ele
tá fogo escondida josé raposo janela e
em troca ela enfrente em la unión
impressão públicos
não não escuta e se ganhar quem era
usual pagou agora foi isso um dos
quadros tanto histórias os a foto saiu e
outra por aí agora calma
não não o ganhei uma história assim bull
como jô isto ao o que eu não consigo
enxergar meu 18 uma da manhã é eu não
consigo o cheiro não posso comer o meu
capitão wilfredo não como é que o
capitão fred por onde eu nem comer tudo
o que está alto está muito alto pra mim
que o que antes serviu vi um ser vivo e
servir meu eu que não entendo muito essa
que está mal escrito
ok sou velho agora as portas e
freqüentes estão fechadas e eu preciso
sair daqui né
com calma
o bar gay mané não aceitou invadida
possa pisar ali uma bomba
eu sei que a primeira volta mas vocês
também deixou passar também pelo que eu
sair daqui com um ferro hospitais no cu
mas para sair o jogo aí o que posso ir
numa listagem ao cair vulgo zé gordo na
qual o senhor esta executava volta
avaliou fred e andar ou não o preço que
já atua na plataforma p hirose qual o
que está acontecendo eu não cheguei a
minha lado de salsicha eu não quero para
minha lata de salsichas futebol que está
a passar com o meu sempre estamos a
oferecer um que quer um quer que foi
pelos âmbito da mesquita al qaeda está a
ser fácil mas com espionagem tem de
apanhar 11 talles fp cuidado do verão o
que considera o itaqui um ambiente
estranho eu estou muito próximos cabeça
com cabeça coxa a cabeça bucha do euro e
diz me tu não vai sobreviver saber se
irei perguntar uma chamada no orçamento
porque o velho meio com a minha
bicicleta um caso de carnita matthews
foi ler o motor do meu carro meu como é
que é possível não ganhei conca carne
o modelo town e uma moeda espera eu
preciso apanhar aqui o pessoal não sei
como é que eu ganhei eu ganhei
quem é o gol de fred é um animal crônica
domicílio ou é uma alucinação peso mas
está em uma ascensão quem é o foxy 2.0 é
uma atração construída para as crianças
o eu é uma pulsão sair eu acho que
é é e uma atração acho que isso aí é
isso foi fácil vim aqui duas perguntas
alô alguém da pizzaria nem fred nem nada
pois já fala em 50 ônibus culpa
unicamente aqui já não saí do meu filho
não fez a pressão e assim o carro assim
vai tudo correr bem não deixar aquela
luz aquela luz não indica nada é só o
mundo ia ficar não deixa passar o mais
gostoso com bicicleta btt tal filho dado
bem filho filho primo joão filho está
tudo bem pode contestar o carro machado
pai e no filho voltou mal isso alguma
coisa que muitas coisas no gol eu deixei
meu pai vai ou não bombas não buscam
calma para o vidro é lá que eu não posso
porque eu não posso sobreviver
não sei como eu sou chato o cheque não
acaba 2000 2001 morto nos conseguir toys
pessoal nós vamos ficar por aqui com
este fait fred são mateus vai você está
num estado já sabem se gostaram deixam
lá e se não estarão não faço nada eu tô
cheio de tesouros atarfe lá fora porque
tem uma foto em luz apontado na matéria